hi guys I'm Tamra chambers and this is
episode a3 of Tamra's never seen you
guys this is this kind of bothered me
the entire episode ah hi guys my name is
Tamra shavers and I fixed my hair okay
now that that very important issue has
been settled I am watching the secret of
NIMH Oh Tanner has never seen okay
well if you haven't seen the secret of
NIMH you need to make that a priority
today because it's incredible and I love
it with all of my heart and it's one of
the best animated Shh it's one of the
best animated shows I've ever seen it's
so so so so so so so so so so sweet
hello Eddie
she wants to be the new star she's
jealous of Ike so if you haven't seen it
it starts off with mrs. Brisby who is
the most courageous pure sweet female
character that I might like maybe that
I've ever seen in an animated cartoon
movie a wonderful strong and courageous
woman character hmm wonder if this movie
is getting any hate I sure I am after
that so she goes and sees mr. ages who
is an adorable old man Mouse and he
stirs up a potion to give to Timmy her
son who has pneumonia and is dying also
I have to assume that having pneumonia
as a mouse is really serious then you
meet Jeremy the bird who's tied up and
string and he's talking about meeting
the love of his life and he's hilarious
and I love him obviously everyone knew
that I was gonna love Jeremy if you've
seen the movie and you're watching this
review you already have called that I am
going to love Jeremy with all of my
heart this dog the shoe is here see what
the Internet can do you feeI here by now
if you defense but now I'm like oh we're
best friends this is great I love this
I'm not gonna fish around a frame at all
we are best friends though
speaking of incredible felines there's a
cat in this movie so obviously it's
already the best movie ever I love that
there's a cat named dragon so much and I
wrote oh this is my notebook with all of
my notes and I wrote down wait there's a
cat named dragon right Game of Thrones
reference later and I didn't so just
know that I was going to and then I
didn't I've not seen the show I did read
the books though I only got the first
four so they go back to mrs. Brisby
house and you see all of her children
and she's got three healthy children and
one sick Timmy then their auntie shrew
shows up auntie swine no siree swine is
a pig you're rats no they're mice oh my
gosh I'm learning so much what I love
about the scene is mrs. Brisby 'he's
healthy son Martin speaks up to mrs.
auntie shrew and it's hilarious and I
wish I was that brave he's like you're a
loudmouth and she's like whoa I've had
enough of that and she leaves and then
she falls down the stairs cuz comedy and
I love it it so cute
I have finally built up the courage to
say this you are loudmouth so you see
mrs. Brisby give Timmy the medicine that
mr. ages gave her just moving it it is
so cute and he can't move for three
weeks that's the deal he won't heal if
he moves out of bed in the next three
weeks first of all number one I will
flip the fuck out if Timmy dies I flip I
don't know what I will flip but I would
flip something over I will flip no
string cheese that was for Ike if he
wasn't gonna come over I was gonna lure
him in with strange
it's his favorite snack okay then you
find out that NIMH means the National
Department of Mental Health's National
Institute
National Institute of Mental Health
because there's no D in in good job
Tamara but that's like so weird that
that is what name means this children's
film is an acronym for a National
Institute of Mental Health and until you
get to the end of the movie and realize
what the story is like what happened
with psyche all the creatures like
you're just like what the fuck why so
then moving day comes and that's when
the farmers plow the lands that the mice
live on so they have to move and it's
terrifying
so I miss this in the beginning there's
this like sorcerer dog I thought it was
a dog it's not it's a rat but I thought
it was like this wizard sorcerer dog
who's watching over all of these mice
this mouse mrs. Brisby and her late
husband Jonathan her husband died
Jonathan it's like I love them and this
is a thing and a meal it's so cut to the
scene after the plow incident and he is
talking about them again and he sees
that she saves her son and stops the
plow and he's like very pressed so she
goes and talks to the great owl who is a
great owl he reminds me of the bad guy
owls and cockadoodle which I loved as a
kid and that's syrup ears and so he
tells her to go and get help from the
rats he said the rats will be helpful my
best friend in sixth grade was my pet
rat named yogurt and he was very helpful
in being my best friend I love when you
go into the rat Slayer and there's all
of this that they're they're generating
energy and like your purpose in life is
to find a way to get their own energy
without stealing from the humans because
they don't want to be stealing and I
think it's so lovely that they have so
much purpose and so much Drive and their
little rats and I love it I love it you
don't have to be large to have purpose
and you can sell purpose if you large to
everyone can approve go rats mrs. Brisby
asks the rats for help and they're like
no and then they're like but she's
Jonathan's wife it's not like she's this
hero that's like I can do anything
no she's fucking scared the whole time
and it's awesome to see her be like but
still I'm still gonna do it because I
need to do it and that is my job and I
love that I think it's such a good
lesson to learn and she's a fucking
little mouse in an animated cartoon and
I was very inspired by her you meet
Nicodemus who is the leader of the rats
and he's the old dog wizard that I saw
in the beginning that you see throughout
the movie and you find out that NIM was
an animal testing site you find out that
through the testing the rats and mice
became really intelligent and they
escaped and the reason they were able to
escape was because her husband Jonathan
was small enough to get through and let
them out
so he's like everyone's hero and it's a
really cool scene that you get to watch
her watch all of this happen because
she's watching through this portal and
she gets to see him being courageous and
you understand now what the amulet was
and that it only glows red if you're
courageous so then you see the rats
moving mrs. Brisby house with Timmy in
it and you see Jenner cutting some
strings and killing Nicodemus Jenner
tries to take her amulet and they kill
Jenner with like this dramatic awesome
fight scene between rats and swords
what's not to love and then her house
starts sinking in the mud
with Timmy and all of her children
inside she's like sobbing it's really
dramatic and I thought that I was gonna
have to flip everything over in my house
because I thought all of them were gonna
die it was really horrific and then the
amulet comes up through the mud comes
back to her you see a flashback of
nicodemus saying if you're courageous at
heart this amulet has a lot of power and
she grabs it it burns her hands and she
still is holding on to it she's so
scared and then the house comes up
through the mud and it's just amazing
it's such a good scene I loved it so
much it was so sweet don bluth you
motherfucker
so mrs. Brisby saves them with a stone
and their houses moved and Timmy lives
and Jeremy the black crow finds love and
she's probably names Jessica or Jess or
Jenny or she just a bluejay seriously
what the fuck is up with all the G hate
didn't and then that's the end and it
was so good and I enjoy it so much I I
grew up with Disney films and I love
them so much but honestly like some of
the better animated movies were not
Disney because they were allowed to go
darker than Disney was gonna go one of
my favorite movies of all time is
Disney's Hunchback of Notre Dom and it's
because I love Disney so much but it was
able to be a darker film and this one
was so like that I love the idea that
children watch this growing up I think
that's really cool that they were able
to see an animated movie something that
they were really interested in a great
story but also something really creepy
and real that's awesome what do you
think Ike any last thoughts
that's exactly what I said coffee me if
you can see the new star you have to
have your own original plot I you see
this you shoot I have to work with